[Musique]
devinette question de conjugaison de
culture générale ou encore de géographie
tout cela en espagnol voilà ce à quoi
ont dû se frotter les 157 collégiens
venus des quatre coins de l'île lors de
la deuxième édition du concours al
Kansas qui s'est tenu dans l'hémicycle
du Palais de la source ce mardi 4 avril
organisé par l'académie de la Réunion ce
concours intercollège a pour but de
tester les connaissances linguistiques
des jeunes ayant choisi l'espagnol comme
langue vivante un challenge pour les
collégiens mais aussi pour les
enseignants qui ont réalisé un vrai
travail collaboratif dans la mise en
place des outils dans le choix des
questions et de la grille d'évaluation
l'enjeu étant de mettre l'accent sur les
connaissances linguistiques mais surtout
culturelles des marmailles cette année
11 établissements chacun représenté par
trois élèves se sont affrontés dans la
bonne humeur soutenue par leur camarades
et professeurs
ils sont impressionnants tout simplement
donc on a vu alors je ne parlerai pas de
disparité mais c'est vrai que chaque
groupe d'élèves a appréhendé ce
moment-là différemment il y a eu plus ou
moins de stress à gérer ça s'est vu et
là parfois c'est une question de
rapidité la plupart des groupes avaient
les réponses et ce qui a des permis de
départager des groupes c'est la rapidité
après une heure de gymnastique
intellectuel l'équipe qui a su se
démarquer en répondant au plus de
questions n'est autre que le collège
milroche de Saint-André
voilà il y avait vraiment trois équipes
qui étaient un petit peu dans pas dans
un mouchoir de poche mais c'est vrai que
c'est l'équipe gagnante a terminé
beaucoup plus tôt mais l'autre équipe
c'est bien défendu aussi lors de la
Gonesse eternos mais c'est vrai que pour
l'équipe gagnante ils ont à cette équipe
a fait preuve d'une rapidité remarquable
impressionnante même je dirais
ému
joyeux de la tête on disait c'est nous
les meilleurs on va gagner
et ben on a gagné comment vous allez
préparer ça avec votre professeur oui on
a fait des ateliers avec la prof
d'espagnol
à l'issue de cette matinée il n'y a pas
que les gagnants qui ont été récompensés
tous les élèves ont pu repartir avec un
cadeau à savoir un ouvrage de Daniel
waxeller sur l'histoire de la Réunion
[Musique]